[Musik]
dort wird ihnen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stell dir vor deine himmelhoch
berlinerin und jetzt meckern motive
schloss lecker garten heimisch mit der
attrappe auf genau
ja das ist auch groß kaufte ihm du es
vertretbar gut was hättest den kaffee
aus fairem handel aber mit mikros fairen
handels scheine bestrafte micro-sim sind
sie nun höhe von blumen sind die elite
gewohnt hat die hand das land
bewirtschaftet
unterdessen ist es so dass kein einziger
hof mit rund um die leute drin wohnen
dass dir das bewirtschaftet
[Musik]
das bauernsterben nimmt kein ende
im durchschnitt sind in den letzten zehn
jahren in der schweiz
jeden tag drei bauernbetriebe
verschwunden vor allem kleinere und
mittlere höfer
die gründe sind sehr unterschiedlich
fehlende nachfolge ungenügendes
einkommen der verlust von kulturland
durch überbauung um mehr über die
angespannte lage in der schweizer
landwirtschaft zu erfahren beobachten
wir vier bauernbetriebe über den
zeitraum eines jahres im berner seeland
liegt der hof von lisa und hans scholl
die shows sind milchbauern mit leib und
seele
[Musik]
das ist nach wie vor der faszination
2008 verwirklichen die chance ihren
lebenstraum einen tiergerechten
bauernhof von fachkundigen beratern
ermutigt setzen sie alles auf eine karte
sie bauen in radelfingen einen laufstall
für 65 tiere
dafür setzen sie ihre gesamten
ersparnisse 1
und sie nehmen einen bankkredit auf
erneuerbare hof ist erst ein paar monate
in betrieb
als der bund im mai 2009 die
milchkontingentierung außer kraft setzt
das resultat eine milchschwemme die
konsequenzen sind fatal
der milchpreis bricht ein für einen
liter milch erhalten die bauern heute
ein drittel weniger
auf derselben wurde
wir sind unterwegs im emmental
[Musik]
ziel ist eine abgelegene alb fast zehn
kilometer von der nächsten ortschaft
entfernt
[Musik]
auf der hinteren flum hörsaal wohnt
familie martin mutter floh vater
valentin und die befreundete melanie
blutiger haben sich hier mit ihren drei
kindern ein paradies geschaffen
leider zu klein um davon leben zu können
schon seit zwei jahren suchen sie einen
bauernhof mit genügend land des kongo
machen sauber sechs metern boulahrouz
mit einem stau und für das man aber
wuchs landwirtschaft könnten betriebe
berichten
so kann man eigentlich nicht nur knapp
überhaupt noch schaffen und so
eigentlich ist jetzt eigentlich wechsel
je nach erforderlicher scharfe kritik
und jetzt wechselt sommerwetter
amtlichen aber wie die ganze sache
stellen das wäre möglich
die machen die mit im land und am besten
hauptbahnhof und kost sand
umfunktioniert gemeinsam wird biologisch
für biologisch-dynamische umstiegen
und mir ist so vorgestellt
ich hoffe verbietet der stahl oder stoff
das team sucht einen hof im großraum
emmental die beiden biolandwirt ihnen
unter allrounder kultivieren in ihrem
garten kräuter und gemüse für den
verkauf auf dem markt in langnau und für
den eigenbedarf den speditionen krise
glaubt schon geklagt sie das lohnplus wo
es nicht absagen
das ist nicht so dass ich meine kinder
schaffe aber bisher führt und das
wahrnehmen der familie h das ist schon
immer differenzierter diese die
biodynamische landwirtschaft schumacher
und das beinhaltet dass es sie vier
jahre und dass irgendeine
biologisch-dynamische bruder ein
landwirtschaftliches diplom ist
notwendig um vom bund direktzahlungen
für einen bauern betrieb zu erhalten
macht vorhaut einem politiker in serie
taumelt der 1 liga aktuell und sicher
einige jahre frau befehl es ist noch gar
nicht am punkt corporate abgabe moment
idee hat vielleicht mal ab ca und es
gibt viele helfer gar nicht lösen aber
es muss endlich vorbei
das gesetz muss der hof gefahr ansieht
muss auch finanzierbar sie
[Musik]
geschlossenen kreislauf ich habe es ganz
wichtig dass du nicht tust politiker ist
dass das schief geht und haut euro
tvt glaubt dass das was gesungen macht
also das quer über alle meine fotos
gemacht aber ich glaube stadtrat das ist
noch möglich ist auch noch die angst
machen wir jetzt natürlich fertig sein
jetzt ja das thema arbeitet sie für sich
entscheiden wie es ist kein metall wie
es weitergeht
das global business braucht was ist es
noch mehr gedanken darüber machen ja
warten
[Musik]
mitten in emmen liegt der bauernhof und
paula und seppi tallinn
als pächter bewirtschaften sie den hof
seit 45 jahren ihre drei kinder sind
erwachsen und längst ausgezogen
vorläufig kann sep ag noch auf seinen
langjährigen knecht aus der slowakei
zählen aber bald so nun alles anders
werden
das gestell gesundheitliche probleme
denn ich auch nur schön und wenn ich
viel gesagt es geht und da gibt es keine
therapie für 60
die aliens haben ein offenes haus
sohn thomas kommt oft zum mittagessen
er ist gelernte autolackierer den hof zu
übernehmen wäre für ihn kein thema
gewesen ist und war es im schnitt wie
die zukunft zu beraten
mit 30 milchkühen hat der hof eine
kritische größe um wirtschaftlich
rentabel zu sein
auch der stall müsste dringend erneuert
werden
[Musik]
ihren hof führen dieser und hans schori
allein um die ganze arbeit ohne knecht
zu bewältigen haben sie einen
melkroboter angeschafft der tag und
nacht läuft die 65 kühe entscheiden
selbst wenn sie gemolken werden wollen
das high-tech-gerät hatte seinen preis
160 tausend franken
die über den erlös aus dem milchverkauf
amortisiert werden müssten
der roboter sehen hat startet mpc
du musst dich heute sparen jetzt mal ja
wenn er die rechte prise darauf
ordentlich ins vergnügen
das wetter ist nicht so dass ich immer
ein thema als mannes die zahlen jetzt
gegen gang aber es ist so dass man
machen
aber wenn es halt nur maschine haben es
nicht leicht
es ist ja um delikte wie er zu den
großen zu den markt doch als muss er
einfach eine million nachmittage im jahr
das ist einfach jetlag hier gegenseitig
scharf das macht mir gedacht habe
für den export für den export gehen
das liegt vor wenn ein echter renner sei
nicht da ist strom bei frank für strom
oder mehreren stunden meiner leute die
nur durch bringt
die yahoo
für dieter lintz gibt es kein zurück
für die ganz laufen die letzten
vorbereitungen seit zwei jahren bereiten
sie sich auf diesen tag vor 30 milchkühe
und die ganze vorhaben werden
versteigert
[Musik]
und noch eine maschine und montagfrüh
und trainer schätzen dass sie eine kette
oder machte nur montag vor einer der
landwirt aus ihrer einschätzung recht
und das schließlich pensionskassen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auf der suche nach einem hof ist das
trio marc gebürtiger auch nach einem
weiteren sommer nicht vorangekommen
aber sie haben kontakt zu einem
bauernehepaar in der nähe gefunden
tina und werner batic kommen ins
pensionsalter und denken daran mit der
landwirtschaft aufzuhören
für melanie valentin und flog könnte
dies die chance sein
wo es puren und im winter um converter
wilden weiß mein arbeitsverhältnis im
winter sind und dass sie meistens nicht
so einfach wie sie oder als aufwärmer
seit über 40 jahren leben werner und
tina partie als biobauern auf dem hof
sankt oswald
sie haben den hof als junge familie
erworben
langsam wird ihnen die anstrengende
arbeit zuviel keines ihrer vier
erwachsenen kinder möchte den betrieb
weiterführen
die boutique scannen den wunsch von
valentin flow und melanie einen eigenen
hof zu bewirtschaften
beide seiten haben vorstellungen wie die
weiterführung des hofes zu gestalten
wäre nett und korrigiert und speaker und
sogar um tun mit dem transport auf dem
markt ohne flotte sind circa factory
fekter im rheinland ist
für mich jetzt eigentlich lehre für wie
viel platz für euch im namen des staates
satz für ribery hat ein restaurator sie
nehmen im moment sie miriam opera nur 34
uhr mez um 1 4 punkte roma sind und ihr
älterer wo haben wir sogar die haben
nehmen ersetzt
ob sich eine gemeinsame zukunft ergeben
kann bleibt ungewiss
loszulassen ist ein schwieriger prozess
ein paar tage vor der band kommt auch
bei sap tallinn wehmut auf
oh mein gott ich war froh wieder um die
pole geholt worden und trete singen ich
danke wird schwer da ist jeden tag
morgens aufgestanden ist
[Musik]
der tag der ganz alles steht bereit
über 100 freiwillige helfer sind im
einsatz
bis zu 2000 besucher werden erwartet
käufer und auch schaulustige
ich war schade so so schön die grüne
wiese dort lernen ein brocken war
eigentlich sehr interessanter in einer
zone also eine oase vor acht uhr war
schön aber das entscheiden andere
das hauptthema heutige steigerung von
der familie recht hat das bewusstein
willkommen heißen
ähnlich schönes frühlingswetter petrus
19 durch und hoffentlich doch so sagt
den verlauf von tag sowie wieder liebe
bianchi schade dass sich für diejenige
volleys am nichts wie andy roddick
hoffen
wenn man eine machtdemonstration
herunterfahren 100 fahren kann zum
morgen zum dritten mal 100 franken ja
wohl nicht genutzt 65 prozent sagt
[Musik]
franke
andre winter oft gefragt
das ganz ähnlich ende haben da herrscht
eine ruhe die berliner und die ist
geprägt von alibaba.com bereits bewiesen
auch die möglichkeit ein anderer 12 19
dann hätte und zwar an der merz am
herzen verortet sich verbraucherinnen
termin steht noch einmal 2002 in
frankreich erzeugt und sich fragen kann
sich frankreichs führender grüner 24 404
oder feucht 160 etagen zwei yachten
drehbuchautor erste früheren geschichten
20 28 828 der franke 2 802 3u sich am
morgen die hohe marina das ruhr geboren
ist am 5 sie hinterlässt ich mache halt
sehen offenbarte sich als kino fand es
gut sie statt mit 80 kilo
ich brauche halt vor allem lucy
ich selbst mache neben reporter steigen
ja mit dem buch spüre und dass man könne
mit mit dem zu schlagen so präsent dass
er hier
restlos alles ist verkauft
die 30 milchkühe haben neue besitzer
noch am selben abend werden sie weg
geführt
[Musik]
es ist komisch morgen nicht die
regierung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf dem land der show riss in
radelfingen haben drei wochen lang
fahrende campiert 40 familien
am abend will die gruppe weiterreisen
noch ein letztes mal bringen die chance
trinkwasser die paar freunden die sie
als entschädigung erhalten sind ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
trotzdem in ihrer schwierigen
finanziellen lage sind lisa und hans
scholl auch über diesen kleinen zustupf
[Musik]
ein geschenk paradies dahin mit paradiso
weiter hier haben wir wohnen hier ist
schön hier sinnvoll
der zusammenbruch des milchpreises hat
bereits vielen schweizer milchbauern das
genick gebrochen
auch für die show riss wird es nun immer
enger
[Applaus]
ein milchbauer muss 365 tage im jahr für
seine tiere da sein
da erstaunt es nicht wenn sich lisa und
hans schori kaum noch erinnern wann sie
das letzte mal in den ferien waren es
circa zwei bis drei jahren
auf dem hof von tina und werner batic
ist es herbst geworden
schweren herzens haben sie sich von den
letzten kühen getrennt ihre hoffnung den
hof gemeinsam mit anderen zu führen hat
sich zerschlagen
das heute dass sie nun nicht mehr
brauchen schränken sie einen
befreundeten bauern schmeckt ja das
hoffe ich dass ich nur an um einen
schritt weh tun wie mir schon klage
sieht das neue musik und ihre kollegen
den ganzen praktische gedanken konami
noch wie heute dass die ganze nacht an
die irgendwo umgeben ist groß was gott
sei dank immer wieder die version noch
heuer wieder machen falls nötig
wir sind verwurzelt als wurzel mit dem
ganzen kombination alter baum sowie ist
untersätze mottoshow aber mir hat am und
im dritten teil ich glaube liebe und
meine projekt landwirtschaft machen da
das wetter das hus ich mein man ehrlich
ist mir sieht wie sie dort heil und bei
mir war mir sehr gut die form kunden
hätten also einen fließenden übergang
miano erwünscht sind und und viano ja
nötig fühlt zum mitmachen zum etat für
das haben wir ganz locker erfolg strebt
oder spaten hätte mir schon sehr nah
lässig wo die mädchen über geil und beim
guitar dass das klappt
ganz klein gibt es kein einziges buch wo
also die print sowie sofort auch
erfahrung mit laufe die buche der grenze
gestiegen
dann will man natürlich geboren wanderte
kann sich wichtige beziehung möglichst
sie wird nicht so zu hause geblieben so
lange als möglich ihrem eigenen haus
wohnen bekommen billig wohnen bei mir
noch nie frickenhausen rosenblüten euro
prämiert regierung der brocken im etat
von sozialer harmonie der grosse druck
den sich nur entscheiden verkauft
hinter sich und muss sich neu
orientieren oder irgendwas der boden
unter die füße
die pattex werden weiterhin in ihrem
bauernhaus wohnen und nur ihr land
verpachten
eine entscheidung wie sie heute viele
schweizer bauern im pensionsalter
treffen
auch deshalb ist es für junge
bauernfamilien schwierig einen bauernhof
zu finden
valentin flow und melanie brauchen
unbedingt einen hof mit wohnhaus stall
und genügend land um ihre pläne zu
verwirklichen so dass sie sich entschied
das land nach wie vor für pachter schaaf
bot die drei hektar
eigentlich muss er einen klasse hat
gekracht ja ich jetzt heute einfach so
gut da hat ihn wahnsinnig reuters hat
ermöglicht haus zum arzt fahren
aber wer weiß was sich dann entwickelt
oder nicht jetzt geht's einfach mal
bitte hat ja genug aus nach verbringt
geben wir sie als apani durch bericht
fertig zum landwirt das spanisch und das
war eigentlich das waren ja betrachter
bruder aber damit bin ich zwar wiederum
osten tätig natürlich bedeutet
beschäftigungsgruppe mit der sache
machen sagte prozent das ist gut das
mache ich gern mal was zukunft bringt
die hoffe natürlich schon dass mir
einfach im leben stehen die hof oder
gefilmt
[Musik]
es bleibt ihnen nichts anderes übrig als
sich weiterhin in geduld zu üben und das
kleine anwesen zu bewirtschaften dass
sie gepachtet haben mit liebe zum detail
und daher eigentlich die steinbecker sie
noch nie hat heute eine aufführung und
nach steuern bei pflanzen und letzte
team oder umgebaut
und wenn wir endlich am hof hat nämlich
dass nach 22 uhr sondern schon in arbeit
auch die kleinsten helfen mit bei den
vorbereitungen für den markt
[Musik]
ein jahr ist seit der ganz vergangen
pauler und seppi tallinn haben glück sie
können im bauernhaus bleiben weil kein
neuer pächter mehr einziehen wird
neben dem stall sind unterdessen die
baumaschinen aufgefahren
und das ist erst der anfang schön ruhig
natürlich schön zum release bereits
becky und schönste usa gut zu den
hunderten höhepunkt kurz and roll band
und formschön buch an die ihr verwachsen
schön sonnig wie hohe axel morgen aber
erst wenn der hof in its history
bevor er in den medien könne und so ich
irgendwie sieht sind wenn du machen
würde jetzt schon machen
das ist schön und kurvenreich und und
die türe einen gott und aus lage ist ein
paar amerikas ist verrückt gut aus
verlag repos mit funde jetzt muss
steigen und arizona gemietet aber keine
liegenschaften ich muss ja finanziell
auch ich stehe für sie muss können
dollar oder 6 3 millionen
vielleicht kommt ist noch gegangen und
eigentlich sind wir froh dass ich so
fertig
[Musik]
den hof suche ist immer noch ein großer
punkt setzt die koala
jk
aber es wird doch für den moment bleibt
der eigenen bauernhof ein traum diesen
traum haben sich schories zwar erfüllt
aber nun ist die finanzielle lage
bedrohlich und belastend
das ist nicht mit alternativen auf bio
das ist die einzige chance dass man sagt
dass man die menge kann auch ak es steht
fest der milchpreis wird auch in naher
zukunft nicht steigen
die bäuerlichen interessen verbände
rufen deshalb zu einer protestaktion vor
dem bundeshaus auf lisa und hans scholl
sind dabei
[Musik]
und sonst machen wir sind topfit schritt
würde ich hier das leben
deutschland besitzt die option
eigentlich bestimmt das
landwirtschaftsgesetz das den
milchbauern ein vertrag zu steht in
welchem preis menge und
zahlungsmodalitäten festgelegt sind
auf diese weise während die milchbauern
weniger der preis willkür der
milchverarbeiter ausgesetzt
im moment will vom bund niemand zu den
vorwürfen stellung in diesem sommer will
er aber über die umsetzung des gesetzes
informieren
das ist
das einfach
sieh zu wie die bude hängen gerahmte mit
der mac mini sollte jedes ganze sparte
aus die große keule raus
aktuell erhalten die bauern im schnitt
noch 1 und 50 rappen für einen liter
milch nur knapp zwei drittel der
herstellungskosten sind damit gedeckt
[Musik]
solche sind vincent ich das gar keiner
und das militär stehen heute aus einem
tank norbert netzwerks weiter aber der
hat jetzt aber das casting zum schneider
ammann
zurück auf dem hof der show riss ihr
täglicher kampf ums überleben geht
weiter an story ist pessimistisch das
braucht eben zeit braucht ob er in der
schweiz berufs kleine bruder maher der
modernen betrieb oder sie schweiz sei
sie ohne butter das wiederkäuen die haut
aus importierten wo aus man an karten
verschenkt nachfrage das bekenntnis der
schweiz auf dieses bekenntnis hoffen
viele bauern viele wohl vergeblich
um zu überleben entscheiden sich lisa
und hans schori zu einem radikalen
schritt
das haben wir aber das ist vielleicht
das jahr machen aber einzigen
technischen
heute gibt es in der schweiz noch rund
52.000 bauernbetriebe das bundesamt für
landwirtschaft schätzt dass sie den
nächsten zehn jahren weitere 10.000
bauernbetriebe aufgeben müssen
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]